bienvenue dans « Comprendre l'information et le calcul quantiques » je m'appelle John Watrous et je suis directeur technique de la formation chez IBM
Quantum il s'agit de la leçon numéro 14 de la série et c'est la deuxième leçon de la quatrième unité qui porte sur la correction
d'erreurs quantiques dans la leçon précédente nous avons jeté un premier regard sur la correction d'erreurs quantiques notamment le code de Shore à neuf qubit qui établit que
la correction d'erreurs quantiques est possible en théorie nous avons aussi discuté de la discrétisation des erreurs qui nous permet
de corriger des erreurs quantiques arbitraires sur des qubit en les projetant effectivement sur des retournements de bit et des retournements de
phase dans cette leçon nous allons aborder le formalisme des stabilisateurs qui est un outil mathématique grâce auquel nous pouvons
spécifier et analyser une large classe de codes correcteurs d'erreurs quantiques connus sous le nom de codes stabilisateurs cela inclut le code de Shore à 9 qubit
ainsi que de nombreux autres exemples notamment des codes qui sont probablement bien mieux adaptés aux dispositifs quantiques réels
que le code de Shore tous les codes correcteurs d'erreurs quantiques ne sont pas des codes stabilisateurs mais beaucoup le sont
y compris tous les exemples que nous verrons dans cette série il existe certes des codes correcteurs d'erreurs quantiques intéressants et potentiellement utiles
qui ne sont pas des codes stabilisateurs mais ils ont tendance à être bien plus complexes et dans tous les cas il n'y a
aucun doute que le formalisme des stabilisateurs est une pierre angulaire des fondements de la correction d'erreurs quantiques et nous allons
l'utiliser intensément pour le reste de l'unité voici un bref aperçu de la leçon nous commencerons par une courte discussion
sur les matrices de Pauli et les produits tensoriels de matrices de Pauli qui peuvent représenter à la fois des opérations sur des qubit ainsi que
des mesures de qubit comme je vais l'expliquer et dans ce contexte nous y faisons souvent référence en tant qu'observables nous reviendrons ensuite
sur le code à répétition et nous verrons comment nous pouvons le décrire à travers les opérations et observables de Pauli ce qui à la fois informera
et mènera à une discussion générale sur les codes stabilisateurs incluant plusieurs exemples des propriétés fondamentales des codes
stabilisateurs et comment nous pouvons réaliser les tâches fondamentales d'encodage de détection d'erreurs et de correction de ces
erreurs nous allons commencer la leçon par une brève discussion sur les opérations de Pauli principalement pour poser les bases du
formalisme des stabilisateurs mais aussi pour observer quelques faits clés et établir une terminologie de base d'abord voici les matrices de Pauli
incluant la matrice identité 2x2 ainsi que les trois matrices de Pauli non-identité que nous noterons
X Y et Z en majuscules pour le reste de la série ces quatre matrices sont à la fois unitaires et hermitiennes et nous pouvons
les identifier avec des opérations sur un qubit y compris des opérations que nous pourrions choisir d'effectuer ainsi que des erreurs comme nous
l'avons discuté dans la leçon précédente les matrices de Pauli non-identité X Y et Z anticommutent entre elles
ce qui signifie que XY est égal à -1 fois YX XZ est égal à -ZX et YZ est égal
à -ZY et tu peux facilement vérifier ces relations en effectuant les multiplications ces relations d'anticommutation
sont très simples mais elles sont d'une importance critique dans le formalisme des stabilisateurs et ailleurs et plus précisément
comme nous allons le voir ces signes moins qui apparaissent quand nous échangeons l'ordre de deux matrices de Pauli non-identité différentes dans un produit correspondent précisément à la
détection des erreurs dans le formalisme des stabilisateurs nous avons aussi les règles de multiplication listées ici chaque
matrice de Pauli est son propre inverse ce qui est cohérent avec le fait qu'elles sont à la fois unitaires et hermitiennes et si tu multiplies deux matrices de Pauli non-identité différentes
entre elles tu obtiendras toujours plus ou moins I fois la matrice de Pauli non-identité restante
en particulier à une phase globale près Y est équivalent à X fois Z ce qui explique notre attention portée aux erreurs X et Z en
correction d'erreurs quantiques X représente un retournement de bit Z représente un retournement de phase et donc à une phase globale près Y représente
ces deux erreurs survenant sur le même qubit ces quatre matrices représentent toutes
des opérations ou des erreurs ou l'absence d'erreur sur un seul qubit mais il est souvent pratique de les combiner en produit tensoriel
pour effectuer des opérations ou des erreurs sur plusieurs qubit pour des raisons de terminologie quand nous faisons référence à une opération de Pauli sur N qubit
nous entendons un produit tensoriel de n quelconques matrices de Pauli comme dans les exemples montrés
ici il est aussi courant d'utiliser le terme opération de Pauli quand il y a une phase globale mais pour garder les choses aussi simples que possible
je vais utiliser le terme opération de Pauli pour signifier simplement un produit tensoriel de matrices de Pauli le poids d'une opération de Pauli sur N qubit
est simplement le nombre de matrices de Pauli non-identité dans le produit tensoriel par exemple le produit tensoriel d'ordre N
de la matrice identité 2x2 avec elle-même est une opération de Pauli de poids zéro un produit tensoriel de deux matrices de Pauli X
et d'un grand nombre de matrices identité est de poids deux et ainsi de suite de façon intuitive le poids d'une opération de Pauli sur N
qubit est le nombre de qubit sur lesquels elle agit de manière non triviale et il est typique que les codes correcteurs d'erreurs quantiques soient
conçus de sorte qu'ils puissent détecter et corriger des erreurs représentées par des opérations de Pauli jusqu'à un certain poids nous pouvons
penser aux opérations de Pauli de différentes façons notamment comme des opérations effectuées intentionnellement par des gates quantiques ainsi
que des erreurs et nous verrons aussi bientôt que les opérations de Pauli peuvent décrire des mesures il est aussi parfois utile
de penser aux opérations de Pauli comme des générateurs de certains ensembles au sens algébrique que tu reconnaîtras peut-être
si tu es familier avec la théorie des groupes si tu n'es pas familier avec la théorie des groupes ce n'est pas grave ce n'est vraiment pas essentiel
pour cette leçon mais si tu veux étudier la correction d'erreurs quantiques en plus grande profondeur tu pourrais trouver que quelques
notions de base de théorie des groupes sont très utiles pour cela de toute façon supposons que P1 à PR soient des opérations de Pauli sur N qubit
ainsi P1 est une opération de Pauli sur N qubit P2 est une opération de Pauli sur N qubit et ainsi de suite quand nous faisons référence à l'ensemble généré par
P1 à PR nous entendons l'ensemble de toutes les matrices que nous pouvons obtenir en multipliant ces matrices entre elles dans
n'importe quelle combinaison et dans n'importe quel ordre en prenant chacune autant de fois que nous le souhaitons nous verrons quelques exemples dans un
moment mais d'abord laisse-moi mentionner la notation que nous utilisons pour désigner cet ensemble l'ensemble généré par P1 à PR est
représenté par P1 à PR séparés par des virgules à l'intérieur de crochets angulaires on pourrait facilement confondre
cette notation avec la notation de Dirac mais cela n'arrive généralement pas et c'est la notation traditionnelle en théorie des
groupes voici un exemple de l'ensemble généré par X Y et Z donc N est égal à un dans cet exemple car il n'y a pas de
produits tensoriels et nous prenons les trois matrices de Pauli non-identité comme générateurs il s'avère qu'il y a
16 matrices qui peuvent être générées en formant des produits incluant ces trois matrices et tu peux raisonner sur cela
à travers les règles de multiplication que nous avons vues plus tôt plus précisément nous pouvons bien sûr obtenir X Y et Z ainsi que l'identité
et en fait nous pouvons aussi obtenir n'importe laquelle de ces quatre matrices fois I 1 ou moins I et c'est
WEBVTT
tout cet ensemble est communément connu sous le nom de groupe de Pauli nous pourrions aussi considérer l'ensemble
généré par seulement x et z et nous obtenons la moitié du groupe de Pauli dans ce cas
et un dernier exemple du moins pour l'instant nous pouvons considérer l'ensemble généré par X tenseur x et z tenseur Z donc N est égal à
deux dans ce cas et nous obtenons seulement quatre éléments cette fois en raison du fait que X tenseur x et z tenseur Z
commutent entre eux les matrices de Pauli et les opérations de Pauli sur N qubit plus généralement décrivent
des opérations unitaires qu'il s'agisse d'erreurs ou d'opérations intentionnelles mais elles décrivent aussi
des mesures pour être plus précis en partant des trois matrices de Pauli non-identité nous pouvons associer chacune de ces
matrices à une mesure projective définie en termes de ses valeurs propres et vecteurs propres et voici à l'écran
les décompositions spectrales de ces matrices qui aideront à clarifier cela en substance quand nous faisons référence à une mesure
X à une mesure Y ou à une mesure Z nous entendons la mesure projective définie par les projections
sur les espaces propres de ces matrices et nous pensons généralement aux valeurs propres comme étant les résultats de mesure correspondants
par exemple une mesure X est une mesure par rapport à la base plus
moins d'un qubit ou alternativement nous pouvons la décrire par l'ensemble contenant les projections ket plus bra plus et ket
moins bra moins une mesure Z d'autre part n'est rien de plus qu'une mesure
en base standard bien que comme je l'ai dit nous identifions parfois les valeurs propres aux résultats de mesure et si nous le faisons
alors les résultats sont plus un et moins un par opposition à 0 et 1 respectivement nous pouvons en fait faire quelque chose
de similaire pour des matrices hermitiennes arbitraires et le terme observable est couramment utilisé dans cette situation pour les matrices de Pauli
et les opérations de Pauli sur N qubit plus généralement nous pouvons effectuer de telles mesures de manière non destructive en utilisant
l'estimation de phase et juste pour être sûr que ce diagramme est clair ici nous effectuons les mesures de manière non destructive sur
le qubit du haut tandis que le qubit du bas est toujours initialisé à un état plus ou en d'autres termes un Hadamard appliqué à un
état zéro parce que c'est ainsi que fonctionne l'estimation de phase remarque que parce que les valeurs propres
sont simplement plus un et moins un dans ce cas nous n'avons besoin que d'un qubit de contrôle qui est le qubit du bas dans ce
diagramme plus que cela serait du gaspillage car il n'y a qu'un seul bit de précision dont il faut se soucier la valeur propre
est soit plus un soit moins un et la mesure est déjà parfaite ainsi le résultat de cette mesure
soit dit en passant c'est-à-dire la mesure en base standard dans le circuit sera zéro pour le résultat de valeur propre plus un
ce qui correspond à l'état plus dans le cas d'une observable X et le résultat est un pour la valeur propre moins un
ou l'état moins dans ce cas tout ce que je viens de dire s'étend naturellement aux opérations de Pauli sur N qubit
à condition de garder à l'esprit que quand nous pensons à une observable nous parlons de mesurer les valeurs propres
et non de mesurer par rapport à une base de vecteurs propres par exemple considère l'opération de Pauli sur deux
qubit Z tenseur Z encore une fois il y a deux valeurs propres plus un et moins un donc la
mesure est décrite par deux projections remarque en particulier que la mesure que nous associons à
cette observable n'est pas la même que mesurer les deux qubit avec une mesure Z ou en d'autres termes une mesure en base standard mais plutôt c'est une mesure projective à deux
résultats où les projections sont sur les espaces engendrés par tous les vecteurs propres correspondant à
chacune des deux valeurs propres plus un et moins un une autre façon d'y penser est que les valeurs propres d'un produit
tensoriel sont des produits des valeurs propres des matrices individuelles dont nous prenons les produits tensoriels et
parce que -1 fois -1 est la même chose que +1 fois +1 par exemple cette mesure ne
distingue pas 0 0 de 1 1 donc si nous mesurions par exemple un état de Bell phi plus avec la mesure
décrite par cette observable nous serions certains d'obtenir le résultat correspondant à la valeur propre plus un
et l'état serait inchangé au lieu de s'effondrer sur 0 0 ou 1 1 ce qui se passerait si nous
effectuions les mesures en base standard sur les deux qubit donc une mesure Z tenseur Z n'est pas
la même chose qu'effectuer deux mesures Z indépendamment mais nous pouvons en fait effectuer des mesures comme celle-ci en utilisant l'estimation de
phase exactement de la même façon qu'avant en utilisant un seul qubit de contrôle comme indiqué dans le circuit diagram qui
se généralise à n'importe quelle opération de Pauli sur N qubit à la place de Z tenseur Z quand nous n'avons que des matrices de Pauli Z
d'ailleurs nous pouvons simplifier le circuit comme ceci et ce que cela révèle ce qui est aussi évident dans les projections qui définissent
la mesure est qu'effectuer une mesure Z tenseur Z sur deux qubit est équivalent à mesurer leur parité
en termes de base standard et cela se généralise au produit tensoriel de n'importe quel nombre de matrices
Z de Pauli ensuite nous allons jeter un second regard sur le code à répétition à trois bits cette fois en le formulant en termes d'opérations de Pauli
ce sera notre premier exemple plutôt simple d'un code stabilisateur et nous discuterons de comment généraliser cette
notion bientôt mais il est utile de voir comment cela fonctionne dans ce cas simple d'abord rappelle-toi que quand nous appliquons le
code à répétition à 3 bits aux qubit nous encodons un état qubit donné Alpha 0 plus beta 1 comme Alpha 000 plus beta 111
et nous allons donner à cet encodage de trois qubit le nom Psi par commodité donc par définition Psi est un encodage valide de trois qubit
d'un état qubit mais si nous voulons le vérifier il suffit de vérifier que les deux équations suivantes sont vraies la
première équation stipule qu'appliquer des opérations Z aux deux qubit les plus à gauche de Psi ne fait rien à Psi ce qui veut dire que
Psi est un vecteur propre de Z tenseur Z tenseur Identité ou simplement ZZ identité en abrégé avec valeur propre un et la deuxième
équation est similaire sauf que les opérations Z sont appliquées aux deux qubit les plus à droite l'idée est si nous pensons à Psi
comme une combinaison linéaire d'états de base standard alors la première équation implique que nous ne pouvons avoir que des coefficients non nuls pour les états de base standard
où les deux bits les plus à gauche ont une parité paire ou de façon équivalente sont égaux et la deuxième équation implique que nous ne pouvons
avoir que des coefficients non nuls pour les états de base standard pour lesquels les deux bits les plus à droite ont une parité paire une autre façon de penser à cela
est de voir ces deux opérations de Pauli comme des observables et si nous mesurions ces deux observables en utilisant le
circuit simplifié que j'ai mentionné il y a un instant alors nous serions certains d'obtenir un résultat de mesure correspondant aux valeurs propres plus un
parce que Psi est un vecteur propre des deux observables avec valeur propre un mais cette version simplifiée du circuit combiné
WEBVTT
pour mesurer indépendamment les observables n'est autre que notre circuit de vérification de parité pour le code à répétition à 3 bits
et nous voyons donc que nos deux équations ensemble sont équivalentes au circuit de vérification de parité donnant 0 0 en sortie
ce qui est le syndrome indiquant qu'aucune erreur n'a été détectée les opérations de Pauli sur trois qubit
ZZ identité et identité ZZ sont appelées générateurs stabilisateurs pour ce code et le stabilisateur du code est l'ensemble
généré par les générateurs stabilisateurs cet ensemble le stabilisateur est un objet mathématique fondamentalement important
associé à ce code et nous approfondirons son rôle au fil de la leçon pour l'instant
je vais juste souligner que nous aurions pu faire un choix différent pour les générateurs par exemple nous aurions pu sélectionner Z identité Z à la place de l'un
ou l'autre des générateurs que nous avons choisis et le code et le stabilisateur seraient exactement les mêmes ensuite nous allons examiner la détection
d'erreurs de retournement de bit pour le code à répétition à trois bits en mettant l'accent sur les interactions et les relations entre les opérations de Pauli
impliquées à savoir les générateurs stabilisateurs et les erreurs elles-mêmes supposons que nous ayons encodé un
qubit en utilisant le code à répétition à trois bits et qu'une erreur de retournement de bit se produise sur le qubit le plus à gauche cela provoque la transformation de notre état Psi
selon l'action d'une opération X ou d'une erreur X sur le qubit le plus à gauche comme nous le savons déjà nous pouvons détecter
cette erreur en effectuant les vérifications de parité pour le code à répétition à trois bits ou de façon équivalente nous pouvons mesurer
l'encodage de manière non destructive en traitant les générateurs stabilisateurs comme des observables commençons par le premier
générateur stabilisateur et voyons ce qui se passe notre état a été affecté par une erreur X et nous voudrions comprendre
comment la mesure du générateur stabilisateur en tant qu'observable est influencée par cette erreur x et z anticommutent tandis que
tout commute avec la matrice identité et il s'ensuit donc que ZZ identité anticommute avec X identité
identité donc nous obtenons un signe moins quand l'ordre est changé et nous savons aussi que ZZ identité ne fait rien à Psi
parce que Psi est un encodage valide d'un qubit et les encodages valides sont toujours des vecteurs propres de valeur propre plus un des deux générateurs stabilisateurs
cela nous laisse avec moins X identité identité appliqué à Psi et donc X identité identité appliqué à
Psi est un vecteur propre de ZZ identité avec valeur propre moins un nous pouvons aussi faire quelque chose de similaire
avec le deuxième générateur stabilisateur mais cette fois l'erreur commute avec le générateur stabilisateur et donc notre
état corrompu est à nouveau un vecteur propre du générateur stabilisateur mais cette fois la valeur propre est positive
un donc notre état corrompu est un vecteur propre des deux générateurs stabilisateurs et que la valeur propre soit plus un ou
moins un est déterminé par le fait que l'erreur commute ou anticommute avec chaque générateur stabilisateur pour le premier
l'erreur et le générateur stabilisateur anticommutent et pour le second ils commutent et ce sera toujours l'un ou l'autre car deux
opérations de Pauli quelconques commutent ou anticommutent tandis que l'état Psi réel ne joue pas vraiment un rôle important
ici sauf pour le fait que les générateurs stabilisateurs agissent trivialement sur cet état donc quand nous réfléchissons à la
détection des erreurs nous n'avons vraiment pas besoin de nous préoccuper de l'état encodé spécifique tout ce qui compte c'est si l'erreur commute ou anticommute
avec chaque générateur stabilisateur faisons donc un tableau avec une ligne pour chaque générateur stabilisateur
et une colonne pour chaque erreur ici j'ai seulement inclus les erreurs correspondant à un seul retournement de bit ainsi
que l'absence d'erreur qui est indiquée par l'identité tensoriée avec elle-même trois fois nous pourrions ajouter d'autres colonnes pour d'autres erreurs si nous le voulions
mais pour l'instant nous allons nous concentrer sur ces erreurs seulement l'entrée dans le tableau est soit plus un soit moins un en fonction du fait
que l'erreur et le générateur stabilisateur commutent ou anticommutent ainsi pour chaque erreur dans le tableau nous pouvons regarder
la colonne correspondante pour voir comment cette erreur va transformer n'importe quel encodage donné en un vecteur propre de valeur propre plus un ou moins un
de chaque générateur stabilisateur ces colonnes correspondent précisément au syndrome que nous obtiendrions des
vérifications de parité qui sont équivalentes aux mesures non destructives des générateurs stabilisateurs en tant
qu'observables bien sûr les entrées dans ce tableau sont des plus un et des moins un plutôt que des zéros et des uns respectivement
et si tu préfères tu peux penser aux syndromes comme étant les chaînes binaires correspondantes plutôt que des colonnes de plus un et de moins un mais il y a une
correspondance directe et juste pour rendre le lien entre les syndromes et les valeurs propres plus clair et direct
je vais faire référence à ces vecteurs de plus un et moins un en tant que syndromes comme avant les syndromes nous disent
quelque chose sur l'erreur qui a eu lieu et en particulier si nous savons que l'une de ces quatre erreurs possibles
s'est produite le syndrome nous indique laquelle c'était et nous pouvons la corriger en appliquant l'erreur à nouveau si nous
le souhaitons ensuite je vais dire encore un peu plus sur les syndromes et en particulier nous allons examiner de plus près
leurs aspects algébriques nos encodages sont des états à trois qubit donc ce sont des vecteurs unitaires dans un
espace vectoriel complexe de dimension huit et ce que font les quatre syndromes possibles c'est découper cet espace de dimension huit
en quatre sous-espaces de dimension deux ce qui signifie que les vecteurs dans l'un quelconque de ces sous-espaces nous donneront toujours le même
syndrome plus en détail ce diagramme illustre comment l'espace de dimension huit est divisé
chaque générateur stabilisateur divise l'espace en deux sous-espaces de même dimension à savoir l'espace des vecteurs propres de valeur propre plus un
et l'espace des vecteurs propres de valeur propre moins un par exemple les vecteurs propres de valeur propre plus un de ZZ identité sont des combinaisons linéaires
d'états de base standard pour lesquels les deux bits les plus à gauche ont une parité paire et les vecteurs propres de valeur propre moins un sont des combinaisons linéaires
d'états de base standard pour lesquels les deux bits les plus à gauche ont une parité impaire et la situation est similaire pour
l'autre générateur stabilisateur sauf que ce sont les deux bits les plus à droite plutôt que les deux plus à gauche donc ces quatre sous-espaces sont faciles à
décrire dans ce cas en raison du fait que c'est un code très simple en particulier le sous-espace
correspondant au syndrome plus un plus un est l'espace engendré par ket 000 et ket 111 qui est l'espace des encodages
valides et c'est appelé l'espace du code et en général les espaces sont engendrés par les états de base standard
qui sont montrés dans les carrés correspondants bien que ce ne soit pas nécessairement aussi clair ou facile à voir les syndromes
partitionnent aussi toutes les opérations de Pauli sur trois qubit qui représentent les erreurs de Pauli possibles pouvant survenir en quatre collections de taille égale
selon quel syndrome cette erreur provoquerait par exemple toute opération de Pauli
qui commute avec les deux générateurs stabilisateurs entraîne le syndrome plus 1 plus 1 et parmi les 64 opérations de Pauli sur trois qubit possibles
il y en a exactement 16 dans cette catégorie incluant les trois mentionnées à l'écran et de même pour les trois autres
WEBVTT
syndromes ce n'est pas évident mais c'est vrai et cette propriété fondamentale que les syndromes partitionnent à la fois l'espace d'état
dans lequel vivent les encodages et toutes les erreurs de Pauli possibles dans l'espace en pièces de taille égale est quelque chose qui est
vrai en général pour les codes stabilisateurs que nous allons bientôt définir précisément bien que ce soit surtout juste une remarque à
ce stade il vaut la peine de mentionner que les opérations de Pauli qui commutent avec les deux générateurs stabilisateurs ou de façon équivalente
les opérations de Pauli qui entraînent le syndrome plus 1 plus 1 mais ne sont pas elles-mêmes proportionnelles à des éléments du stabilisateur se comportent exactement comme
des opérations de Pauli sur un seul qubit sur le qubit logique que nous avons encodé par exemple XXX commute avec
les deux générateurs stabilisateurs mais n'est pas proportionnel à un élément du stabilisateur et en effet c'est clair si tu
réfléchis à ce code un moment que l'effet que cette opération a sur un encodage est équivalent à un gate X sur
le qubit logique qui a été encodé et encore une fois cela se généralise à tous les codes stabilisateurs il est maintenant temps de définir les codes stabilisateurs
en général et la façon dont cela fonctionne c'est que nous faisons quelque chose de complètement analogue à ce que nous venons de discuter pour
le code à répétition à trois bits sauf que nous choisissons des générateurs stabilisateurs différents que j'appelle P1
à PR pour les besoins de cette explication ces générateurs stabilisateurs doivent tous être des opérations de Pauli sur N qubit
où N est le nombre de qubit utilisés pour l'encodage et nous ne pouvons pas simplement choisir n'importe quel ensemble de générateurs stabilisateurs ils
doivent satisfaire quelques conditions de base d'abord les générateurs stabilisateurs doivent tous commuter
entre eux dans le cas du code à répétition à trois bits nous n'avons pas pris note de cela mais il est facile d'observer que ZZ identité et identité
ZZ commutent en effet car Z commute avec lui-même et tout commute avec
l'identité pour les codes stabilisateurs avec des générateurs stabilisateurs plus compliqués d'autre part notamment des codes où nous avons
à la fois des X et des Z apparaissant dans les générateurs stabilisateurs c'est une condition importante qui doit être
vérifiée une façon de penser à la nécessité de cette condition est que nous allons traiter les générateurs stabilisateurs comme des observables et en exigeant qu'ils
commutent tous nous nous assurons que l'ordre dans lequel nous effectuons ces mesures ne
change rien deuxièmement les générateurs stabilisateurs doivent former un ensemble générateur dit minimal ce qui signifie que si nous en retirions
un nous obtiendrions un stabilisateur plus petit et une façon d'exprimer cela mathématiquement est montrée ici à l'écran
à proprement parler cette condition n'est pas vraiment essentielle à la façon dont un code stabilisateur fonctionne de manière opérationnelle
et il est parfois logique de penser à des ensembles générateurs non minimaux comme nous le verrons dans la prochaine leçon mais
pour analyser les codes stabilisateurs et expliquer leurs propriétés nous allons supposer que cette condition est en
place fondamentalement cette condition garantit que chaque observable que nous mesurons pour obtenir le syndrome ajoute
des informations sur les erreurs possibles plutôt que d'être redondante et de donner des résultats qui pourraient facilement être inférés des autres générateurs stabilisateurs en tant
qu'observables et enfin il doit être le cas qu'au moins un vecteur non nul soit fixé par tous
les générateurs stabilisateurs et cela s'avère être équivalent à exiger que -1 fois l'identité sur N qubit ne soit
pas contenu dans le stabilisateur ce n'est pas évident mais le point est qu'il est possible de choisir un ensemble générateur minimal
d'opérations de Pauli sur N qubit qui commutent toutes entre elles et pourtant aucun vecteur n'est simultanément un vecteur propre de valeur propre plus un
de toutes et nous ne voulons pas nous préoccuper de cette possibilité car les codes sans encodages valides ne sont pas
intéressants donc ce sont les exigences sur les générateurs stabilisateurs pour un code stabilisateur et si nous avons bien un ensemble de générateurs qui
satisfait ces conditions alors nous avons un code stabilisateur valide et nous pouvons considérer ses propriétés il existe de nombreux
codes stabilisateurs différents avec diverses propriétés qui les rendent intéressants ou non mais ils satisfont tous certaines propriétés
de base qui rappellent celles que nous avons déjà observées pour le code à répétition à trois bits
nous allons examiner quelques exemples bientôt mais avant cela laisse-moi mentionner que quand nous faisons référence à l'espace du code d'un code stabilisateur nous entendons le sous-espace
de l'espace d'état sur N qubit qui inclut chaque vecteur qui est simultanément un vecteur propre de valeur propre plus un de chacun des
générateurs stabilisateurs c'est le sous-espace de l'espace d'état sur N qubit dans lequel vivent les encodages valides et nous en dirons plus
sur ce sous-espace au fil de la leçon maintenant regardons quelques exemples de codes stabilisateurs
voici l'exemple que nous avons déjà discuté le code à répétition ordinaire à 3 bits et nous pouvons aussi exprimer la
version modifiée de ce code de la leçon précédente qui peut détecter un retournement de phase au lieu d'un retournement de bit comme un code stabilisateur comme indiqué
ici cette fois les générateurs stabilisateurs mesurent des observables XX plutôt que des observables ZZ donc ce sont essentiellement
des vérifications de parité dans la base plus moins plutôt que dans la base standard dans les deux cas nous pouvons
immédiatement voir que nous avons un code stabilisateur valide parce que les générateurs stabilisateurs commutent ce sont des ensembles
générateurs minimaux et l'espace du code est non trivial comme nous le savons déjà mais nous pouvons aussi voir assez clairement que nous
ne pouvons pas générer -1 fois l'identité et voici le code de Shore à 9 qubit qui est aussi un code stabilisateur
exprimé par des générateurs stabilisateurs dans ce cas nous avons essentiellement trois copies du code à répétition à trois bits
une pour chacun des trois blocs de trois qubit ainsi que les deux derniers générateurs stabilisateurs qui
prennent une forme qui rappelle le circuit que nous avons vu dans la leçon précédente pour détecter les retournements de phase pour ce
code une autre façon de penser à ces deux derniers générateurs stabilisateurs est qu'ils prennent exactement la même forme que ce que nous
avons pour le code à répétition à trois bits pour les retournements de phase sauf que nous substituons XXX à X et la raison de cela
est que XXX correspond à une opération X sur le qubit logique encodé en utilisant le code à répétition à 3 bits mais
c'est une remarque et ce n'est pas quelque chose à s'inquiéter maintenant au cas où ce ne serait pas clair nous allons ensuite jeter un coup d'œil à quelques
autres exemples mais avant cela laisse-moi mentionner que les gens omettent souvent les symboles de produit tensoriel quand ils décrivent les codes stabilisateurs parce que cela a tendance à
les rendre plus faciles à lire donc voici à quoi ressemblent ces codes sans les symboles de produit tensoriel
mais bien sûr ce sont des produits tensoriels et non des produits matriciels ordinaires par exemple nous supprimons simplement les symboles de produit tensoriel pour que ce soit moins
encombré et les motifs soient plus clairs voici un autre exemple c'est appelé
le code de Steane à 7 qubit et il a des caractéristiques assez remarquables nous y reviendrons
de temps en temps au cours des leçons restantes de l'unité mais pour l'instant nous pouvons simplement vérifier que c'est un code stabilisateur valide
en particulier les trois premiers générateurs stabilisateurs commutent clairement entre eux parce que Z commute avec
WEBVTT
lui-même et l'identité commute avec tout et la situation est similaire pour les trois derniers il reste donc à
vérifier que si nous prenons un des générateurs stabilisateurs Z et un des générateurs stabilisateurs X alors ils commutent
et il est suffisamment facile de passer en revue les neuf paires possibles pour vérifier que dans tous ces cas nous aurons toujours
un X et un Z alignés dans la même position un nombre pair de fois donc les deux générateurs vont commuter tout comme
XX et ZZ commutent c'est un ensemble générateur minimal et il a un espace du code non trivial mais
je ne vais pas essayer d'argumenter cela dans cette vidéo et je vais plutôt te laisser y réfléchir si tu le souhaites le code de Steane à 7 qubit est similaire
au code de Shore à 9 qubit en ce sens qu'il encode un seul qubit et permet la correction d'une erreur arbitraire sur un qubit mais il
ne nécessite que sept qubit plutôt que neuf ce n'est pas le plus petit nombre de qubit requis pour qu'un code correcteur d'erreurs
encode un qubit et corrige une erreur arbitraire sur un seul qubit voici un code stabilisateur qui est
généralement simplement appelé le code à cinq qubit qui encode aussi un seul qubit et peut corriger une erreur arbitraire sur un seul qubit
et cinq est le plus petit nombre de qubit pour lequel c'est possible voici un autre exemple de
code stabilisateur bien qu'il ne s'agisse pas vraiment d'un code à proprement parler dans le sens où l'espace du code est
de dimension un en particulier l'espace du code pour ce code est l'espace engendré par un ebit ou en d'autres termes un état de Bell phi plus
donc tu ne peux pas vraiment encoder des qubit avec ce code mais c'est quand même un code stabilisateur valide où l'espace du code
se trouve être de dimension un et il est possible de faire quelque chose de similaire pour un état
GHZ donc voilà quelques exemples de codes stabilisateurs et nous verrons infiniment plus d'exemples dans la
prochaine leçon supposons que nous ayons un code stabilisateur une question naturelle à poser à son sujet
peut-être la toute première question qui vient à l'esprit est combien de qubit encode-t-il cette question a une réponse très simple
et pour l'expliquer soyons précis sur le code stabilisateur considéré nous avons R générateurs stabilisateurs sur N qubit
P1 à PR qui satisfont les trois exigences que j'ai mentionnées plus tôt à savoir que les
générateurs stabilisateurs commutent tous entre eux c'est un ensemble générateur minimal donc nous n'obtiendrions pas le même
stabilisateur si nous retirions un des générateurs et il y a au moins un vecteur non nul dans l'espace du code
comme le théorème montré à l'écran l'indique il doit alors être que l'espace du code du code stabilisateur a
la dimension 2 puissance N moins R ou une autre façon de dire cela est que nous pouvons encoder N
moins R qubit en utilisant ce code donc de façon intuitive nous avons N qubit dans nos encodages et chaque
générateur stabilisateur enlève effectivement un qubit en termes de combien de qubit nous pouvons encoder
ce théorème n'est pas trop difficile à prouver et je vais te montrer une preuve dans un moment mais d'abord nous allons regarder juste
quelques exemples en commençant par le code à répétition ordinaire à 3 bits nous avons trois qubit dans nos
encodages donc N est égal à trois et il y a R égal à 2 générateurs stabilisateurs et donc nous pouvons encoder un
qubit en utilisant ce code remarque que cela ne concerne pas lesquelles ou combien d'erreurs peuvent être détectées ou
corrigées c'est une question différente c'est juste une affirmation sur la dimension de l'espace du code
pour un autre exemple considère le code à cinq qubit ici nous avons cinq qubit et quatre
générateurs stabilisateurs donc encore une fois l'espace du code a la dimension deux ce qui signifie que nous pouvons encoder un qubit en utilisant ce
code et un dernier exemple pour l'instant pour le code stabilisateur de l'ebit nous avons deux qubit et deux générateurs stabilisateurs donc
l'espace du code est de dimension un et comme je l'ai mentionné plus tôt c'est l'espace engendré par l'état de Bell phi plus
nous verrons plus d'exemples au fil de notre avancée notamment des codes où nous pouvons encoder plus d'un qubit mais pour l'instant
voyons comment nous pouvons prouver le théorème la première chose que nous devons observer c'est que parce que les générateurs stabilisateurs
commutent et forment un ensemble générateur minimal et parce que chaque opération de Pauli est son propre inverse chaque
élément du stabilisateur peut être exprimé de manière unique comme un produit où nous élevons chaque générateur stabilisateur
PK à la puissance AK où chaque AK est soit zéro soit un et nous multiplions ensuite les résultats
ensemble une autre façon de dire cela est que nous obtenons chaque élément du stabilisateur en multipliant ensemble un sous-ensemble des
générateurs stabilisateurs et nous n'obtenons jamais le même élément stabilisateur de sous-ensembles différents et une chose que
cela implique c'est que la seule façon d'exprimer l'opération identité sur N qubit de cette façon est de mettre toutes les puissances à
zéro ensuite définissons pi K comme la projection sur l'espace propre de valeur propre plus un de PK pour chaque K de 1 à R et il y a
une formule simple pour cette projection nous pouvons simplement faire la moyenne de PK avec l'identité sur N qubit ce qui laisse effectivement les valeurs propres
plus un intactes et met à zéro toutes les valeurs propres
moins un maintenant l'espace du code est défini comme l'ensemble de tous les vecteurs qui sont simultanément des vecteurs propres de valeur propre plus un de tous
les générateurs stabilisateurs étant donné que les générateurs stabilisateurs commutent les projections doivent aussi commuter et cela
implique que le produit de ces projections est aussi une projection et en particulier c'est la projection sur
l'intersection des sous-espaces sur lesquels les projections individuelles projettent ou en d'autres termes c'est la projection sur
l'espace du code nous pouvons développer ce produit et ce que nous obtenons c'est la moyenne sur chaque
élément du stabilisateur et enfin parce que la dimension d'un sous-espace quelconque est égale à
la trace de la projection sur ce sous-espace nous trouvons que la dimension de l'espace du code est la moyenne des traces sur les éléments du
stabilisateur mais à l'exception de l'opération identité sur N qubit tous les éléments du stabilisateur doivent avoir
une trace égale à zéro parce que les trois matrices de Pauli non-identité ont toutes une trace égale à zéro la trace de l'opération identité sur N qubit
est 2 puissance N et donc nous trouvons que la dimension de l'espace du code est 2 puissance N moins R ce qui prouve le
théorème ensuite je vais dire juste un peu sur la façon dont les qubit peuvent être encodés en utilisant les codes stabilisateurs mais pour cela nous devons d'abord
introduire les opérations de Clifford les opérations de Clifford sont des opérations unitaires sur n'importe quel nombre de
qubit qui peuvent être implémentées par des circuits quantiques avec un ensemble restreint de gates à savoir les gates Hadamard les gates S
et les gates CNOT remarque que les gates T ne sont pas inclus ni les gates de Toffoli ou de Fredkin
et non seulement ces gates ne sont pas inclus dans cette liste mais en fait il n'est pas possible d'implémenter ces gates
WEBVTT
en utilisant ceux de la liste donc ce ne sont pas des opérations de Clifford les opérations de Pauli d'autre part
sont des opérations de Clifford et plus précisément elles peuvent être implémentées en utilisant des séquences de gates Hadamard et S
donc c'est une façon simple de définir les opérations de Clifford mais cela n'explique pas vraiment pourquoi elles sont définies de
cette façon ni ce qui est spécial à propos de cette collection particulière de gates voici la vraie raison pour laquelle les opérations de Clifford sont définies comme
cela à une phase globale près les opérations de Clifford sur N qubit sont précisément les opérations
unitaires qui transforment toujours les opérations de Pauli en opérations de Pauli par conjugaison pour être plus précis une opération
unitaire sur N bits U est une opération de Clifford à une phase globale près si et seulement si pour chaque opération de Pauli sur N qubit
conjuguer cette opération de Pauli par U nous donne plus ou moins un fois une opération de Pauli sur N qubit
potentiellement différente tu peux facilement vérifier que cette propriété est vraie pour les gates Hadamard les gates S
et les gates CNOT donc elle est nécessairement vraie pour les circuits construits à partir de ces gates ce qui est plus difficile à prouver c'est que ça marche
dans l'autre sens c'est-à-dire que si nous avons une opération unitaire U particulière sur N bits qui satisfait cette
propriété alors il doit être possible de l'implémenter à une phase globale près en utilisant seulement des gates Hadamard S et CNOT
je ne vais pas parcourir la preuve de cette implication mais c'est vrai et tu peux la chercher si tu es
intéressé les opérations de Clifford ne sont pas universelles pour le calcul quantique ce qui signifie que nous ne pouvons pas exécuter des
calculs quantiques arbitraires en utilisant seulement des gates Hadamard S et CNOT en fait pour une valeur donnée de N il n'y a qu'un nombre fini
d'opérations de Clifford sur N qubit donc c'est un ensemble discret d'opérations donc contrairement à un
ensemble universel de gates quantiques nous ne pouvons pas approximer des opérations unitaires arbitraires à un niveau de précision désiré quelconque et en
fait effectuer des opérations de Clifford sur des états de base standard suivi de mesures en base standard ne peut pas nous permettre
d'effectuer des calculs qui dépassent la portée des algorithmes classiques parce que nous pouvons simuler efficacement des calculs de cette forme
de façon classique ce fait est connu sous le nom de théorème de Gottesman-Knill et la preuve standard de ce théorème est en un certain sens
basée sur le formalisme des stabilisateurs en particulier la façon dont cela fonctionne c'est que nous pouvons suivre la façon dont les opérations de Clifford transforment les opérations de Pauli
par conjugaison ce qui peut être fait efficacement et ensuite inférer de cela ce que les calculs font aux
qubit donc quel rapport cela a-t-il avec les codes stabilisateurs eh bien un code stabilisateur nous fournit
un espace du code d'une certaine dimension et nous avons la liberté d'utiliser cet espace du code comme nous le voulons donc rien ne nous force à encoder
des qubit dans cet espace d'une manière spécifique mais il sera toujours possible d'effectuer un encodage en utilisant une opération de Clifford
comme encoder c'est bien parce que les opérations de Clifford sont relativement simples par rapport aux opérations unitaires arbitraires
il existe des façons d'optimiser leur implémentation qui fonctionnent de manière similaire à la preuve du théorème de Gottesman
-Knill et en conséquence les circuits pour les implémenter n'ont jamais besoin d'être très
grands en particulier nous pouvons toujours effectuer un encodage en utilisant une opération de Clifford qui nécessite un peu moins qu'un nombre quadratique de gates
parce que c'est en fait vrai pour chaque opération de Clifford donc le résultat est que pour un code stabilisateur donné il est toujours
possible d'encoder des qubit efficacement en utilisant ce code et les outils mathématiques qui sont utiles pour comprendre les opérations de Clifford peuvent aider à ce
processus par exemple voici un encoder pour le code de Steane à 7 qubit c'est une opération de Clifford et il s'avère que
celui-ci n'a même pas besoin de gates S pour les codes stabilisateurs généraux la détection d'erreurs fonctionne de la façon suivante
comme avant nous allons supposer que nous avons des générateurs stabilisateurs sur N qubit P1 à PR et nous allons laisser E être une opération de Pauli sur N qubit
représentant une erreur hypothétique sur un encodage nous considérons seulement les opérations de Pauli
comme erreurs d'ailleurs parce que la discrétisation des erreurs fonctionne de la même façon pour les codes stabilisateurs arbitraires que pour le code de Shore à 9 qubit
la façon dont nous vérifions les erreurs est de mesurer chacun des générateurs stabilisateurs en tant
qu'observables il y a R générateurs stabilisateurs donc cela signifie R résultats où chacun est un plus un ou un moins
un ou une valeur binaire si tu préfères associer zéro à plus un et un à moins un et ces R résultats
ensemble forment le syndrome tout comme nous avions pour le code à répétition à trois bits quand R était égal à
deux en général il y a trois cas possibles pour l'erreur E en termes de sa détection et ils sont les suivants d'abord
il pourrait être que E est dans le stabilisateur ce qui signifie qu'il est possible de générer E à partir des générateurs stabilisateurs ou
de façon légèrement plus générale il pourrait être que E est équivalent à un élément stabilisateur à une phase globale
près dans ce cas E n'est pas vraiment une erreur du tout parce qu'elle n'a aucun effet dans l'espace du code sauf peut-être
injecter une phase globale qui n'a aucun effet donc nous n'avons pas du tout à nous inquiéter des erreurs comme celle-ci quelle que soit
l'action non triviale qu'elle pourrait avoir se produit en dehors de l'espace du code donc cela ne nous concerne pas
bien plus préoccupante est la possibilité que E ne soit pas dans le stabilisateur même à une phase globale près mais
qu'elle commute néanmoins avec chacun de nos générateurs stabilisateurs rappelle-toi que c'est
l'anticommutation de l'erreur avec un générateur stabilisateur qui fait apparaître un moins un quelque part dans le syndrome
mais cela ne se produit pas dans ce cas donc c'est une erreur qui change réellement les vecteurs dans l'espace du code de manière
non triviale et nous le savons parce que sinon elle serait proportionnelle à un élément stabilisateur mais elle passe
inaperçue par le code donc c'est le mauvais cas nous avons une erreur qui peut potentiellement changer
l'information quantique que nous avons encodée mais le code ne s'en rend pas compte par exemple pour le code à répétition à trois bits
XXX tombe dans cette catégorie et la dernière possibilité est que E
anticommute avec au moins un des générateurs stabilisateurs et cela signifie que le code détecte cette erreur parce que
nous obtiendrons un syndrome avec au moins un moins un quelque part ce qui indique que quelque chose ne va pas et nous devrons essayer de corriger cette erreur
d'une façon ou d'une autre donc ce sont les possibilités pour des raisons de terminologie
quand nous faisons référence à la distance d'un code stabilisateur nous entendons le poids minimum d'une opération de Pauli tombant
dans la deuxième catégorie c'est-à-dire qu'elle change l'espace du code de manière non triviale mais le code ne
la détecte pas et quand nous disons qu'un code stabilisateur est un code stabilisateur [[N,M,D]] en utilisant
des doubles crochets comme indiqué à l'écran cela signifie que les encodages ont une longueur de N qubit le
WEBVTT
code est capable d'encoder M qubit donc l'espace du code a la dimension 2 puissance M et sa distance est D donc une erreur doit avoir
un poids D ou plus pour changer l'état logique du qubit que nous avons encodé sans être détectée comme une
erreur nous allons maintenant examiner le code de Steane à 7 qubit comme exemple et nous allons déterminer quelle est sa distance
voici les générateurs stabilisateurs pour ce code et rappelle-toi que la distance est le poids minimum d'une opération de Pauli sur N qubit
qui commute avec tous les générateurs stabilisateurs mais n'est pas elle-même dans le stabilisateur ni
proportionnelle à un élément du stabilisateur ce que nous allons déterminer c'est que ce code a une distance
trois la façon dont nous allons déterminer cela est de d'abord considérer toute opération de Pauli ayant un poids d'au plus deux et nous allons
conclure que la seule façon qu'elle puisse commuter avec les six générateurs stabilisateurs est qu'elle soit l'identité qui est toujours un élément du
stabilisateur donc supposons que les matrices de Pauli potentiellement non-identité qui forment cette opération que nous allons
appeler P et Q apparaissent dans les deux positions les plus à gauche c'est juste un cas et nous devons
considérer toutes les autres positions possibles pour ces matrices de Pauli potentiellement non-identité mais l'argument est essentiellement le même pour tous
les emplacements possibles eh bien par hypothèse cette opération commute avec tous les six
générateurs stabilisateurs donc en particulier elle commute avec celui-ci et elle commute aussi avec celui-là
Q s'aligne avec la matrice identité dans les deux de ces générateurs c'est pourquoi nous avons choisi ces deux et nous avons des matrices
identité dans les cinq positions les plus à droite de cette erreur et donc nous concluons que P doit commuter avec X
et Z parce que sinon cette erreur anticommmuterait avec l'un de ces deux générateurs mais la seule matrice de Pauli qui
commute avec X et Z est l'identité donc P doit être l'identité et maintenant que nous le savons nous
pouvons choisir deux autres générateurs stabilisateurs qui ont un X et un Z dans la deuxième position à partir de la gauche et nous pouvons
tirer une conclusion similaire à propos de Q donc il n'y a aucun moyen pour une erreur de poids au plus 2 de passer inaperçue par ce code
à moins qu'il ne s'agisse simplement de l'opération identité qui est dans le stabilisateur donc ce n'est pas vraiment une
erreur d'autre part il existe des opérations de Pauli de poids trois qui commutent avec les six générateurs stabilisateurs
mais ne sont pas proportionnelles à des éléments stabilisateurs et voici deux exemples donc nous avons conclu que ce
code a une distance trois la dernière chose que nous allons discuter dans cette leçon c'est la correction des erreurs pour les codes
stabilisateurs comme d'habitude nous allons supposer que notre code est spécifié par des générateurs stabilisateurs sur N qubit
P1 à PR et commençons par réfléchir un peu à toutes les erreurs possibles qui pourraient
se produire il y a 2 puissance R syndromes possibles et comme je l'ai mentionné plus tôt dans la leçon ces syndromes partitionnent toutes
les opérations de Pauli sur N qubit possibles en collections de taille égale donc cela signifie 4 puissance N divisé par 2 puissance R opérations de Pauli
dans chaque ensemble donc quand nous voyons un syndrome particulier il pourrait être que n'importe laquelle de ces erreurs de 4 puissance N divisé par 2
puissance R est responsable nous surcomptons un peu ici cependant parce que certaines de ces
erreurs ont exactement le même effet sur l'espace du code en particulier si nous avons une erreur E et nous multiplions E par un quelconque
élément stabilisateur S alors nous allons obtenir une autre erreur qui a exactement le même effet dans l'espace du code que E donc
ce sont des erreurs équivalentes le stabilisateur a 2 puissance R éléments et si nous en tenons compte alors nous trouvons
que pour chaque syndrome il y a 4 puissance N moins R classes d'équivalence d'erreurs qui auraient pu provoquer ce
syndrome et ce que cela signifie c'est qu'à moins que R soit égal à N auquel cas nous avons un espace du code de dimension un et
donc nous ne pouvons encoder aucun qubit du tout il ne sera pas possible de corriger chaque erreur que nous pouvons détecter à la place
ce que nous devons faire c'est choisir juste une opération de correction pour chaque syndrome dans l'espoir de corriger juste une classe d'erreurs équivalentes
alors comment devons-nous choisir quelle correction effectuer pour chaque syndrome une stratégie naturelle est de choisir
l'opération de Pauli de poids le plus faible qui provoque le syndrome que nous mesurons avec l'idée que les opérations de Pauli de poids plus faible
représentent des explications plus probables pour ce syndrome cela pourrait ne pas être le cas réellement
pour certains modèles de bruit et une autre stratégie naturelle est de calculer d'une façon ou d'une autre l'erreur la plus probable qui cause le
syndrome donné mais pour l'instant nous allons simplement considérer la stratégie où nous essayons de corriger les erreurs en sélectionnant l'opération de Pauli de poids le plus faible causant le
syndrome pour un code stabilisateur de distance D cette stratégie nous permettra toujours de corriger des erreurs ayant un poids strictement
inférieur à la moitié de D ou en d'autres termes un poids d'au plus D moins 1 divisé par 2 et je vais expliquer brièvement pourquoi c'est
le cas cela montrera par exemple que le code de Steane à 7 qubit peut corriger toute erreur de Pauli de poids un et par la
discrétisation des erreurs cela signifie que tout comme le code de Shore à 9 qubit le code de Steane peut corriger une erreur arbitraire
sur un qubit donc voici comment cela fonctionne imagine que ce cercle représente toutes les opérations de Pauli possibles
qui entraînent le syndrome tout plus 1 qui est le syndrome suggérant qu'aucune erreur ne s'est produite
et que tout va bien parmi ces opérations nous avons des éléments du stabilisateur ou vraiment
des opérations qui sont proportionnelles à des éléments du stabilisateur et nous avons aussi des erreurs non triviales qui changent l'espace du code d'une façon ou d'une autre mais ne sont pas
détectées par le code et nous savons par la définition de distance que chaque opération de Pauli dans cette catégorie doit avoir un poids d'au moins
D car D est défini comme le poids minimum de ces opérations nous avons aussi des opérations de Pauli
qui provoquent d'autres syndromes à apparaître et nous pourrions considérer chaque syndrome tour à tour si nous le souhaitons mais ici nous imaginons simplement
qu'un tel syndrome S est apparu maintenant imagine que E est une erreur dans cette
catégorie qui a un poids strictement inférieur à la moitié de la distance D eh bien nous ne savons pas que c'est
nécessairement l'opération de Pauli de poids minimum dans ce cercle donc prenons C comme l'opération de poids minimum dans cet ensemble ou l'une d'elles en cas
d'égalité donc il pourrait être que C est égal à E ou peut-être pas mais parce que C a
un poids minimum nous savons qu'il ne peut pas avoir un poids plus grand que le poids de E parce que C est aussi dans l'ensemble
et il a un poids minimal donc l'opération de correction C doit avoir un poids strictement inférieur à la moitié de
D alors que se passe-t-il si nous appliquons cette correction C à l'état de notre qubit après que l'erreur E
se soit produite la réponse est que l'état que nous obtenons est C fois E multiplié à l'encodage original parce que nous multiplions d'abord
par E c'était l'erreur et ensuite nous multiplions par C pour essayer de la corriger et ce produit doit être dans
WEBVTT
le stabilisateur ou proportionnel à un élément du stabilisateur et voici pourquoi d'abord parce que E et C nous donnent le
même syndrome C fois E doit nous donner le syndrome tout plus un c'est parce que pour un
générateur stabilisateur donné soit C et E commutent tous les deux avec ce générateur soit ils anticommutent tous les deux c'est forcément le même pour
les deux parce que les syndromes sont les mêmes et si tu y réfléchis un moment cela implique que C fois E doit
commuter avec tous les générateurs stabilisateurs et enfin C fois E doit être
dans le stabilisateur parce que son poids ne peut pas être plus grand que la somme des poids de C et E et donc son poids
est strictement inférieur à D et cela signifie que nous corrigeons avec succès E parce qu'appliquer E suivi de C ne fait rien à
l'espace du code donc c'est bien mais il y a juste un problème et c'est que pour les codes stabilisateurs
en général c'est un problème difficile sur le plan computationnel de calculer l'opération de poids le plus faible causant un syndrome donné
et en effet c'est vrai même pour les codes classiques que dans ce contexte nous pouvons considérer comme des codes stabilisateurs
où nous n'avons que des matrices identité et des matrices de Pauli Z apparaissant comme facteurs tensoriels dans les générateurs stabilisateurs
donc contrairement à l'étape d'encodage les opérations de Clifford ne viennent pas à notre secours cette fois et la seule solution raisonnable
est de choisir des codes spécifiques pour lesquels de bonnes corrections peuvent être calculées efficacement et il n'y a pas de recette pour
cela en termes simples concevoir des codes stabilisateurs comme cela fait partie de l'aspect artistique
de la conception de codes quantiques et c'est un bon endroit pour s'arrêter dans cette leçon j'espère que tu me rejoindras
pour la prochaine leçon dans laquelle nous allons examiner des constructions de codes quantiques spécifiques notamment des codes qui illustrent l'aspect artistique de la conception de codes quantiques
d'une façon assez spectaculaire au revoir pour l'instant